[Musique]
le concours du plus beau collège
fleuries 2010 est mise en place par le
département a débuté 20 collèges ont
participé à l'embellissement de leur
établissement les élèves de classes ulis
du collège bourbon mis du coeur à
l'ouvragé pour réaliser divers potager
dans leur établissement mal dessinés sur
une feuille
on a fait des mesures on a regardé les
placements et tout est à prime 1 à choix
parce que là on a
réserver
et tous fait les repères
la grèce est encore plus beau on aime le
collège et on aime on aime le truc qu'on
l'a fait donc on est fiable
j'aime et je tombe bien c'est comment la
réparer deux collèges bureau on apprend
des trucs et on sait bien on a bien du
lot
l'objectif c'est vraiment ça c'était de
permettre de s'approprier à la fois leur
leur lieu de vie et en même temps de les
rapprocher un peu de la nature pour leur
faire découvrir la nature des mois
d'implication le jury a félicité le
travail accompli il ya vraiment un
travail colossal on a pu voir le avant
et le après et on peut dire que c'est
vraiment impressionnant parce que il ya
eu
de gros travaux c'est pas juste des
justes planté voilà et hop on met 1
petit ticket pour dire c'est tel plan
non un vrai travail de recherche de
comprendre comment la dans la nature ça
fonctionne comment les légumes poussent
qu'est ce qu'il faut de l'eau de
l'entretien et surtout beaucoup de temps
pour réaliser leur collège idéal chaque
établissement un bénéficier d'une somme
de 3500 euros pour le département ce
concours permet aux jeunes de
s'approprier leur collège et d'en être
fier c'est valorisant parce que il prend
soin de leur établissement il
il prend et prennent connaissance du
patrimoine notamment des fruits et
légumes des des aromates blanc temps
donc c'est un passage de relais qui est
un très positif
le jury visitera les vins collège
jusqu'au 16 juin puis déterminera le
lauréat du plus beau collège fleury 2017
[Musique]